THE MESSAGE THEY DO NOT CARE
ABOUT YOU AT ALL, AND THEY'RE NO
LONGER PRETENDING.
J.D. VANCE, I KNOW YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT STUDENT LOAN
DEBT.
IS THIS THE WAY TO ADDRESS IT?
>> CERTAINLY NOT, TUCKER.
YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD
THIS IS EFFECTIVELY A BAIL-OUT
FOR A SUPER CORRUPT EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
IF YOU WANT TO GIVE STUDENT DEBT
RELIEF UNDER PENALIZE THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BENEFITED FROM THIS
CORRUPT SYSTEM, NOT ASKING
PLUMBERS IN OHIO TO SUBSIDIZE
THE LIFE DECISION OF
COLLEGE-EDUCATED YOUNG PEOPLE,
PRIMARILY YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WILL
MAKE A LOT OF MONEY OVER THE
COURSE OF THEIR LIFETIME ANYWAY.
NO.
THIS IS EXACTLY THE WRONG WAY TO
DO IT.
IF YOU GIVE THE BAIL-OUT TO THE
UNIVERSITY ADMINISTRATORS,
THEY'LL KEEP DOUBLING DOWN ON
WHAT THEY'VE DONE, EFFECTIVELY
INDOCTRINATING OUR KIDS, NOT
EDUCATING THEM, GIVING THEM
USEFUL SKILLS FOR THE JOB
MARKET, BUT INDOCTRINATING THEM
AND GETTING A SMALL-CRAFT
ADVISORIES WINDFALL FROM JOE
BIDEN IN THE PROCESS.
IT'S CORRUPT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY REPUBLICANS DON'T SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS.
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT
STUDENTS ARE SO CRIPPLED BY DEBT
THEY CAN'T BEGIN ADULT LIVES.
OKAY?
THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM.
WE SHOULD NOT DENY IT.
BUT THE PEOPLE WHO CAUSED THE
PROBLEM, WHO BENEFITED FROM THE
PROBLEM, WHO DEFRAUDED THESE
STUDENTS, ARE NOT PAYING.
LIKE WHY IS IT SO HARD FOR
REPUBLICANS TO SAY, HEY, YALE,
IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO PAY
REPARATIONS TO YOUR STUDENTS?
>> NOT ONLY ARE THEY NOT PAYING,
TUCKER, THEY'RE BEING REWARDED
BY THIS POLICY, MAKING IT SUCH A
HUGE MISTAKE.
THERE'S A POLITICAL DIMENSION TO
THIS.
OF COURSE I'M RUNNING AGAINST
TIM RYAN, DEMOCRAT FROM OHIO,
WHO'S BEEN ON EVERY SIDE OF THE
STUDENT DEBT ISSUE.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THIS, TWO
MONTHS BEFORE THE ELECTION, JOE
BIDEN HAS GIVEN A SMALL-CRAFT
ADVISORIES WINDFALL TO
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DONORS.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO FIGHT BACK AT
JDVANCE.COM.
THIS HAS DIRECT IMPLICATIONS FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
IF YOU LOOK BEHIND OUR BAD
POLICIES, WHETHER IT'S THE
STUDENT BAIL-OUT, THE
GLOBALIZATION, MOVING STUFF TO
CHINA, WHATEVER YOU WANT TO SAY,
IT'S VERY OFTEN A MASSIVE
TRANSFER OF WEALTH FROM MIDDLE
CLASS HARD-WORKING PEOPLE TO THE
UPPER CLASS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IS, A
MASSIVE BAIL-OUT FOR PEOPLE WHO
MADE BAD DECISIONS AND DOING
WELL ECONOMICALLY.
WHEN I SAY THAT, I MEAN THE
COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS OF
COURSE.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE A WORSE
POLICY, A POLICY THAT SOLVES FEW
OF OUR PROBLEMS AND HARMS MUCH
MORE PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: AND REWARDS THE WORST
PEOPLE, IT REALLY DOES.